hi we're the cost of birds of prey we're
here with BuzzFeed and we're going to do
a quiz to find out which character we
are all right first one choose the wild
animal you'd love to have as a pet
assuming it wouldn't murder you a hyena
a snake a tiger bats a leopard or I'll
stick to dogs thanks Austin to dogs
names know this is hard I mean I really
want a hyena after right I just yeah Oh
a bat is tempting because that's also
very cute but I'm gonna go with how you
know I think it's between the big cats
for me I think I'm gonna go with
leopards I changed my mind I mean I
think about would be cool to you I when
I was only a Philippines I Pat this bat
it's name was Count Olaf and it was so
cute and it actually really nice
how would your friends describe you
behind your back funny kind independent
confident intelligent ambitious I don't
know I'd actually love to ask them I
know each other I think yeah Margot I
would say super kind yeah I would say
that I would say yeah I'd say kind kind
for offer for all of you guys but you're
also funny I know we're too good
choose the musical artists you'd like to
create the soundtrack of your life with
Beyonce Stevie Nicks Cher
I'm just saying mary j blige why didn't
i mary j blige don't panic Rihanna oh I
don't know what are you guys gonna say I
want it to be Beyonce
but I feel like I would be ultimate
Stevie Nicks and Rihanna I think I'm
probably more likely a Stevie
yeah mr. Johnson I'm gonna go really
yeah I love see UNIX but I feel like
Rihanna soar I don't know it just feels
really good
I know I'm so torn because I work out to
Rihanna I mean she really and a Beyonce
like I don't know if Stevie Nicks and
Fleetwood Mac it's just I did Stevie
Nicks choose the color that speaks to
your true or are you purple green yellow
red blue or black I'm gonna say yellow
I'm yellow pathless very countries I
what is very I know I know but then I
thought I'm just in character yes but I
feel wet yeah Brett's a great colour
passionate fiery strong I feel like blue
feels like a reflection maybe a few
choose the DC hero you would most likely
hang out with Wonder Woman flash Batman
Aquaman cyborg what she's am having a
Wonder Woman it was between Wonder Woman
or Aquaman I feel like all of them would
be very absent friends you turn to say
something that just wouldn't be there
pick on I'm gonna choose to zoom because
I would just want to like just eat a
bunch of junk food all day and like be a
child and go to like the carnival I'm
gonna say Aquaman because I'm hoping he
could give me some sort of device that
would allow me to breathe underwater
that really so cool like to go to
Atlantis he can ride like toxins I'm
like sea horses and honestly the hair
floating I mean that was so cool that
was my favorite thing
choose an activity to do with your
friends on a Friday night get dinner and
see a movie order pizza and have a
slumber party go dancing do a planned
group activity like a wine tasting start
an underground Fight Club drink drink
drink go dancing I'm like between order
pizza and have a slumber party and dance
at the slumber party we need this as an
option I would really like to start them
on the ground like I said summer party
because I feel like all of them are a
little like 21 another so Bryce yeah
that looks like a drink am i light we
got a problem and finally choose a
literal bird of prey Malkin Oh hawk
vulture bran eagle or no thanks Birds
freaking cute I'm scared they're gonna
poop on me that's good luck it is bird
poop is good luck embrace okay well I'm
gonna go with an owl I think it makes
sense cuz black Canary's kind of like a
dress is the most sort of down-to-earth
wow you can be a little kept to yourself
at first you have a voice that demands
to be heard literally and figuratively
you're calm cool collected and always on
top of your game yeah yeah I got you got
Harley Quinn you're the truth you're the
true definition of a wild child you're
confident independent and incredibly fun
to be around but you're not afraid to
knock a few skulls together if the
situation calls for it these are so cool
I love these I really want to do it
again I know I know I wanna press retake
[Music]